from Georgia Tech who's taking some time
at Facebook right now but she's gonna be
talking to us about connecting and
vision and language interaction right
thanks thanks Andrea thanks for having
me and so I'm gonna I'm gonna talk about
learning by playing within this space of
connecting vision language and some
common sense reasoning and so my my
background is in computer vision and so
in sort of semantic image understanding
we've traditionally been interested in
problems where you take an image like
this and you try and figure out where
all the objects are is this what the
scene type is is this a college campus
is gonna be each is an office is it
taken indoors is it taken outdoors where
are the people what are they doing how
are they interacting with each other and
so on right but more recently sort of a
small set of researchers in this space
have gotten interested in trying to not
just understand the image but also
translate this understanding off the
image to words and communicate it to a
human in a natural way right so be it
things like describing this image in a
sentence or maybe telling a short story
about this image or maybe answering a
question about this image and someday
maybe even having a natural language
dialogue with an agent that's grounded
in this visual content and so the space
of understanding images mapping this
understanding to natural language and
communicating this in a way that is very
natural and human like I think this
intersection is becoming more and more
interesting and so we've made as a
community a lot of progress in
connecting two of those circles
connecting images to language right so
we can now we now have algorithms that
can automatically take an image like
this and describe it in a sentence like
man in blue wetsuit is surfing on wave
or take an image like this and see a
group of young people playing a game of
Frisbee for this image seeing a
cowardess part in the middle of nowhere
or a part of Rockley on a stove right so
become quite good at sort of recognizing
the obvious things that we seen in image
stitching it together to form a natural
sounding sentence and conveying that
back right but if you think about what
it would take to
scribe an image like this right if I if
I asked you to describe it some of you
might describe it as a man is rescued
from a stroke that is hanging
dangerously from a bridge right so I
think machines today would be ok with
sort of spitting out man bridge hanging
truck and so on but if you think about
what it takes to say words like rescued
and dangerous you realize that the
system needs a sense of what must have
happened just before this image was
taken what is likely to happen a few
seconds after this what intentions of
people in this scene probably are and so
on to be able to say words like rescued
and dangerous right and so you sort of
need this common sense reasoning if you
were the common sense understanding of
the world and how it functions to be
able to produce outputs like this and so
one question that people have looked at
it so well so how do we where do we
gather in this common sense knowledge
from right and one good response has
been that we can use all the texts that
surround us on the web but it's just
every book that's been written up and
try to take advantage of that to learn
this Commons its knowledge about how the
world works and that makes sense in a
lot of cases but one issue with text is
that it is known to suffer from
reporting bias right so text is written
by humans to communicate with other
humans we don't like talking to each
other about boring mundane comments and
stuff we like talk to each other about
things that are unusual and interesting
and as a result it lends itself to be
particularly bad in some situations to
learn exactly this common mundane
knowledge about how the world works it's
more likely that man bites a dog then
dog bites a man it's less likely in text
it is more likely that man bites a dog
than dog bites a man but that's not what
you want to learn and in fact those are
exactly the kinds of examples that I
wanted to show also that if you look at
how often these different phenomena are
mentioned with respect to people in text
and if you try to use that frequency as
a proxy for how often this happens in
the world you would end up concluding
that people inhale six times as often as
they exhale and maybe what's worse is
that people get murdered 17 times as
often as they
right but here's here's another one
again these are different body parts
that are mentioned with respect to
people and if you use this as a proxy
for how often people have those body
parts you would conclude that people
have heads 1100 times as often as they
have gall bladders that's not the case
it's just that we don't like talking
about gall bladders too much right and
so it doesn't it doesn't show up in text
and so that that's an issue and so sort
of coming from a computer vision
background the thought was well instead
of trying to rely on text that was
explicitly written by humans to
communicate with other humans is there a
way to just sort of watch the world
around us right just use the visual data
that tells us what's going on in the
world and leverage that structure to
learn this common-sense knowledge right
and there is a lot of structure in the
visual world right so if I show you this
image and I ask you to describe it you
might say these are two professors
conversing in front of a blackboard
right but if I now change just one
subtle thing about this image your
description will change right you might
say that these are two professors
standing in front of a blackboard right
and so the signal that gaze of two
people relative to each other different
shades whether two people are talking to
each other versus just standing around
is the RIT structure that we could learn
from the visual world but that's hard to
do right it would be hard to do this for
a few different reasons one is we
typically lack this visual density it's
hard for me to find two real images that
differ from each other just in terms of
for example gaze of two people but where
the resultant semantic meaning changes
right where do I find data like that
right even if I had that data detecting
basic things like I would need sort of
everything annotated in this image for
example something as minut as the gaze
of these two people only then would I be
able to learn what that means in terms
of the semantics right and so then your
response when we evaluate a computer
vision researcher why do you need
annotations you should just go ahead and
detect everything right but it turns out
that even with all the progress deep
learning has made we can't detect every
single thing every single semantic
feature in an image to be able to learn
this rich connection right and so this
sort of puts us in a bit of a chicken
and egg problem right on one hand I'm
saying I want to learn common sense so
that I can do a better job of
understanding the image and
communicating it to a human but here I
am saying that in order to learn this
calm
since I first need to solve computer
vision so that I can extract all the
semantic features that I care about and
learned this mapping and so then the
question was well how do we try and
break out of the cycle right and so the
way we thought of doing that was by
questioning whether you even need photo
realism in the first place if what
you're interested in doing is learning
semantic common-sense about the world
right and the claim but what I'm
claiming is that the answer is no that
if what I'm trying to learn is
common-sense knowledge then that
knowledge doesn't lie in the low-level
RGB values of the pixels it lies in the
semantics of the scene and so all right
all I care about is a semantically rich
scene a semantically rich visual world
even if it's not photorealistic right
and so with that thought we introduce
these two characters Mike and Jenny and
they had their own world with sort of a
variety of toys and food items and
indoor objects outdoor objects animals
Mike and Jenny can have different
expressions different poses and sort of
with this fairly simple interface and
fairly simple world we can get people to
interactively create visual data for us
right semantically rich scenes where
they can move objects around they can
flip them left to right they can have a
few different scales and just with a few
interactions you have a fairly rich
scene where if I asked you to sit down
and write sort of a short paragraph
describing what's going on it wouldn't
feel very unnatural to you right you
would be able to tell us what's going on
here right and so what I'll do now is
I'll give you several examples of how
we've taken advantage of this
interaction modality well people can
create the visual data for us to learn
from for for several different tasks all
right so one of the first things we did
was the following
we took a sentence like Mike fights off
a bear by giving him a hot dog while
Jenny runs away and we asked several
different people to depict this sentence
to us in this in this interface that I
showed you right and the interesting
thing is if I ask each one of you to
create the scene you will all create
scenes that do have that meaning but
have different objects present in them
there may or may not be trees the trees
may or may not have fruits where exactly
Mike and jenni are will be different
clouds Sun all of that sort of will vary
but what's consistent in all of them is
that Mike is facing the bed he's holding
a hot dog and Jenny is running off in
the opposite direction right and so this
is something that you can learn from
this setup right it would be hard for
you to find ten real images that all
have the same meaning so that I can sit
down and figure out what is it about
these images that contributor to that
meaning right but here because you are
active interactively collecting data
from users I can sample ten fifty
hundred whatever Mechanical Turk allows
me to do different samples of visual
interpretations of this exact same
sentence right and so we collected a
data set like that we took these
thousand different semantic losses and
by semantic losses I mean these thousand
different sentences and we had ten
people on Mechanical Turk create a scene
for each one of those and then they're
sort of fun things you can do right and
one thing to remember by the way is that
this scene is sort of trivially fully
annotated right it's a it's an it's a
synthetic image that has that we have
created so we know exactly where
everything is we know all the
expressions all the poses and everything
of all the objects that are present here
then so you can start asking phone
questions like which visual features are
important for the semantic meaning or
which words correlate to specific visual
features and so you can basically learn
a mapping between the visual features
and semantic meaning or language through
through this data right and the
interesting thing here is that you had
full control over the density of the
distribution that you're learning from
if I wanted a very heavy sampling off
the same concept in this case literally
the exact same semantics being
replicated multiple times in the visual
scene you can do that with this and so
here's one illustration of what we can
do as a result of this mapping we can
now take as input a short description
like Jenni is catching the ball Mike is
kicking the ball the table is next to
the tree and we can sort of parse this
with some basic NLP techniques and then
using this automatically generate sort
of a scene from scratch that depicts
these sentences right so we can take as
input a sentence or a description and
output a scene in this virtual world
that would correspond to this meaning
there is no tree that's a good point
so the original scene had a tree and the
tree got dropped in the NLP processing
that we were using at the time this is
from 2013 so some a few years ago but
that processing dropped the tree and so
we did end up creating a dream another
interesting thing is it just says ball
it doesn't specify what kind of a ball
ground truth happened to have an
American football and what we ended up
creating was a European Indian the other
football right for a soccer ball so do
you try to model it control it in some
way no we just treat them all as a crowd
or just as one sort of average human and
so we're not reasoning about the fact
that if the if the tour card was
European and if if it said football and
they would use this versus if they were
American and it said football it would
use this we don't model for that in this
case it's not even specified it's under
specified so it could end up sampling
either one even if we were modeling that
unless we gave the agent a personality
like being European or American right so
it it assumes the it assumes access to
the library of clipart so it's not
generating the appearance of Jenny or
the appearance of Mike it is generating
it is deciding what pose to give Jenny
and what expression to give Chinese it's
picking the variables from within the
clipart library yeah
is it a sentence that was in the
training centers it's a fresh sentence
the vocabulary I'm sure overlaps because
things like Jenny and ball and catching
kicking tables next to tree all of those
are common enough concepts but I'm sure
those concepts are in isolation occurred
in the training set but this
construction is a test sentence that
wasn't seen before yes Jenny I will say
so if you if you're literally talking
about Jenny versus Anna then no because
we had told two workers that this person
is called Jenny and this person is
called Mike and actually Mike and Jenny
are quite popular on Mechanical Turk if
any of you do crowdsourcing you're
welcome to sort of browse through the
forums they all still talk about them
but no so we don't know to us Jenny is
the only way of referring to this
clipart number 17 if you're talking
about synonyms in general that instead
of kicking if it was something like
throwing which is similar the only way
we would know that those two might have
similar positions of the object with
respect to the subject is if we've seen
that during training so if we have seen
people talk about kicking and we've seen
people talk about throwing and we
realize that objects end up in place
similarly we would learn done so this
was all so this was early so now if we
were to do this we would probably use
things like embeddings of words which
would already convey some semantics
learnt from text and so we would already
know a priori that maybe throwing and
kicking have relations but this word
doesn't doesn't know that so you
automatically generated one includes a
cloud and the Sun but this is not
explicitly stated in the sentence is
there way to control for whether or not
the system thinks that the cloud and Sun
correlates to Mike and Jenny
specifically or it's like over
generalizing or under generalizing right
so what it's doing is it's it's based on
the sentence it's updating potentials of
how likely each object is to be there
and there's also a prior on that so the
system has a sense for a priority what
are the chances that there is a Sun what
are the chances that there is a cloud
and so unless there's a
things stated in the sentence that
decreases the so for example if it said
and it's raining then the model from the
training data would have known that if
it rains that typically isn't a Sun and
so the word raining would reduce the
probability of the Sun being there
relative to the prior but there's
nothing in this sentence that
discourages the cloud in the Sun so just
from any probability its sampling so
sometimes we'll get a cloud sometimes
you won't get a cloud if it's not
relevant if it doesn't mess with the
semantics basically don't mention the
weather will it could it like be biased
or the cloud partly cloudy day or yeah
if the training data was biased towards
a partly cloudy day it's it's yeah it's
gonna sample from that so that would
happen you would have control over that
if you wanted it to not listen to the
prior too much you would be able to turn
that down and just focus on what's
explicitly said and it is yeah so
sometimes so it would be interesting to
look at 10 different samplings of the
scenes for the same description and I'm
sure the Sun will be in and out and the
clouds would mean
right so I agree that whatever we've
learned is how to generate images in
Mike and Jenny's world and I towards the
end of the talk I will show you how we
use this to generalize to something real
but I want to point out that I'm not I
wasn't saying that I want to generate
realistic images right my goal is not to
be able to learn a model that can
generate realistic images my goal is to
learn common-sense knowledge that would
then generalize to realistic scenarios
where I can take advantage of that
common-sense knowledge right so the
common-sense knowledge that I want to
learn I will eventually I haven't talked
exactly about how this relates to common
sense I will get there but the idea
would be to see if we can use this
abstract world to learn common sense
that does generalize to the real world
need not be real images and it will
become clear as I as I get towards the
end of the talk
any other questions all right
all right so here's one other example of
something we did to show you this sort
of interesting things you can do because
you get to control the density of the
data so in this case instead of trying
to learn something in sort of just the
genetic semantics of kids playing in a
part like it was in the previous case
here we're only interested in seeing in
learning what it looks like for two
people to be interacting with each other
and so we did was we gave Mechanical
Turk workers these interface here you
can see that the poses are soft you can
pick a couple of different genders a few
different colors of hair and so on if
you're asking them to show us what it
looks like for a person dancing with
another person so far it looks like a
person is hitting another person but
then as soon as they change the
expression the meaning of the scene
changed right and so what we can do is
sort of repeat that process again right
I can tell them I can ask 50 different
peoples to show me what it looks like
for person a to be dancing with person
be walking with person B holding hands
with person be arguing with person be
talking to person B and so on
and so here's just to give you a sense
yes not just the final product right we
do keep track of that we haven't done
anything to make use of that so far but
we do keep track of all intermediate
stages that lead to that yes and so just
to give you a sense for the kinds of
things Mechanical Turk workers will
create for these different concepts here
are some examples of jumping over
holding hands with dancing with and I
find that people often so every so often
I'll hear a talk where they say oh these
are mechanical torque workers obviously
did they did not do a great job and I
feel the need to sort of push back on
that that in our experience they do
right like if you look at all the
different poses that they've created of
people dancing with each other and the
amount of detail that they put in at
least I was pleasantly it was quite nice
for us to see that and then once we had
this sort of taking a step towards
seeing if it can generalize to deal to
the real world we wanted to see if we
can use this as training data and then
use real images of people interacting
with each other to then recognize what
the interaction is right and so this
scenario would be the during training
the system has not seen any
example right so in that sense it's sort
of zero short all it has seen is some
one depicting interactively to the agent
what this interaction looks like through
just the simple clipart interface right
and we're not generalizing from pixels
to pixels right you wouldn't expect that
to happen but what we're generalizing is
from pose and expressions to poses and
expressions detected in these real
images and what we find is you can do
above charts right so it gives you it's
statistically significantly above chance
performance it's not sort of the
performance that you get you would get
the same performance if you had just two
or three examples of real images and
right so if you train on just two or
three real examples and then test on
real images that performance is about
the same as training on 50 of these
synthetic examples to the engine to
generalize to real images so it's not
enough of a ratio for me to advocate
that this is how you should be learning
how to interact with people I think
right now it's still easier to just try
and get images from the web and learn
from that but it was still an
interesting conceptual experiment to see
to what extent this generalizes yes
tracting features like yes so we right
so we took an off-the-shelf exactly so
we do compare to what was the state of
the art pose detector at the time and if
you use that as a feature extractor what
accuracy would you get versus if we
assume ground truth pose so we assume
that whoever is working on going from
pixels to semantics has done their job
well then to what extent would the
semantics from here transferred here
there's also other sort of feature level
issues in the sense that this is just a
2d canvas right there's no out of plane
rotation or sort of a coming closer to
the camera or anything like that and
these real images have all of that so
none of that is generalizing so if you
really wanted to push on using this as
an interface to train for recognizing
interactions between people one thing
that would help a lot is have this
interface be a little bit more
complicated before an actual 3d
interface where people can move people
around in 3d then I think that would get
you much better
so when the attackers give you the
example of something like dance wins do
you get one instance from them where do
you get a sequencer we get multiple
people to detect depict that to us so we
asked 50 different workers to create for
a single worker they would give us just
one illustration for each concept so if
we I think we had about 60 different
concepts in this data set so that worker
is free to give us anywhere from 1 to 60
depending on how many will hits they are
willing to do the same thing so we
actually do we encourage diversity in
certain ways so for example in this case
we initialize the poses of the people
somewhat randomly in hopes that assuming
workers want to do as less work as
necessary they'll sort of converge to
some local minima whichever is a dancing
pose relative to that initialization and
same thing with Mike and Jenny we gave
them access to a subset of the clip art
which was randomly sampled so sometimes
they would see a son sometimes they
wouldn't see a son and that would
encourage them to create different
scenes
all right so a third set up within which
we explored the use of again having
control over the density of data that
you get was for this problem of visual
question answering and so the task is
given an image and a free-form question
about this image we want to train agents
that can answer this question and
there's been a lot of work in this space
in the past few years
you see questions like what color are
our eyes when you detect small objects
and recognize the color how many slices
of pizza are there so you need to count
is this a vegetarian pizza so you might
need access to some external knowledge
base that tells you that the presence of
meat might imply not vegetarian and so
on right so this is just to give you a
sense for what the problem statement is
given any image any question we want to
train a system that can answer it and
we've made a lot of progress in the
sense that now so state of the art about
a year and a half ago was at about 55 56
% today it's at 68% and human accuracy
inter-human agreement is that about 83%
so just to give you a sense right so
it's been very exciting you can now
there are online demos where you can
upload an image to ask a question in and
get an answer back and it makes sense a
lot of times but one issue that happens
in these in a lot of these v/q a visual
question on setting settings is that
there is a heavy language bias right and
what I mean by that is the following
that for a lot of these datasets if you
ask the question is there a clock and if
you just say yes you would be right 98
percent of the time right if is the man
wearing glasses you just say yes you'll
be right 94 percent of the time are the
lights on yes you'd be right 85 percent
of the time do you see a don't even
listen to the rest of the question don't
even look at the image just say yes and
you'll be right 87 percent of the time
right and now I'm sure you guys are
wondering that why would that be the
case right how can the lights beyond 90
or 85 percent of the time right and the
reason that happens in these data sets
right it doesn't happen in the real
world the reason it happens in these
data sets is that people were when
you're collecting the data set people
who are asking questions while looking
at the image so you think of asking
about a clock tower only when you
actually see your clock tower in the
image right so at a test time and also
during training you see is there a clock
tower in this image only for images that
actually have a clock
and so your model just learns to say yes
and it will give you a good accuracies
and everything just kind of works out
right and and and so that's an issue
right and so that was hindering progress
on sort of these binary questions in
particular where there is a heavy bias
towards saying yes and it's actually not
just a bias towards saying yes in some
cases there's a bias towards no so if
the question starts with should this
person be doing bla the answer is
usually no because you think about
asking that only in images where someone
is doing something they shouldn't be
doing that's not a good idea right so
it's actually not just about yes versus
no it's just that the framing of the
question
gives away information about whether the
likely answer is going to be yes or no
and that's problematic especially coming
from a computer vision standpoint if
you're trying to use visual question
answering as a benchmark to measure how
well these computer vision algorithms
are actually understanding the image
right so the language bias can be quite
annoying from that perspective and so we
wanted to try and see if we can rectify
this right and we have this tool that
lets you control the density of visual
data that you look at and so what we did
there is the one of the week your data
sets that's that that we've created has
these questions on these clipart images
and so on this image the original
question was is there a place to set
other than the floor and the answer was
no and so what we did is we asked people
we showed them this image and we asked
them to modify the scene as little as
necessary so that the answer becomes yes
right so we want them to modify the
scene so that the answer to the question
is there a place to sit other than the
floor becomes yes and so in this case
the person chooses to bring in a couch
because once there is a couch there is a
place other than the floor that someone
can sit on right and we can do this for
every single question for every single
binary question for every image in the
dataset and so what that gives us is
this nice setup where you now have two
complimentary scenes that are globally
very similar but they have some subtle
difference in them as a result of which
the answer to a question is yes for one
and no for the other right so in this
case is the goal walking the bike is yes
here and no here holistically the images
are very similar but there's a subtle
difference in the interaction between
the bike and the girl that changes the
answer right and so now the language
only prior can get you nothing it's just
chance performance right the answer
could be yes or no and you really have
to look at the image and not just the
image that
portion of the image to be able to
figure out what the right answer is
Trident so this again is the result of
us having access to the density of data
on which we not just train but also test
so just to give you a sense for this if
your task was if you make the task
really hard whether you're given two
images you're given these complimentary
scenes and only if your model managed to
manages to answer the question correctly
for both those images do you get a point
if you get even one of them wrong you
get 0 points right so in that setup if
you look at sort of the original
unbalanced situation where there was a
heavy bias if you just answered
questions based on the question alone
you now have zero accuracy because based
on the question alone you're always
gonna predict the same answer and so you
will always get one of these two images
wrong right so you get zero accuracy if
you add in the holistic image features
it made some difference but it couldn't
help much right and that was that that
was what I was saying earlier that the
image didn't have much of a role to play
if you're training on just the
unbalanced data right but on this
balance side question alone again can't
buy you anything but now the image
really matters if you train your models
on this balanced set that has these two
complimentary scenes and your model has
learned to be able to tell the
difference of what makes the answered
yes versus no the image features
actually make a bigger difference right
does this make sense and then if you
make the model a little bit more
sophisticated where instead of just
looking at the whole image based on the
question it parses it to figure out what
the primary object is what the secondary
object is and what the relation is and
then explicitly aligns these to figure
out here's the goal here's the bike and
then decides if the interaction is
walking or not right so this is a more
detailed computer vision algorithm
that's backing this vqs system what we
find is that this attention based model
so the model that decides where to look
and then answer the question can give
you more improvements right so in the
unbalanced case it gives you some
improvement it's not too exciting but in
the balanced case where the model has
been trained on the balance data so it
can actually learn the visual concepts
you see a bigger improvement in
performance yes
kind of guilt towards very specific
questions because if my question was is
the picture realistic so you don't know
what to attend to direct your attention
beautiful picture right and so in in
this case even the tupple so the couple
has this primary object secondary object
and relation set up so and it is allowed
to have the latter two fields be blank
so in this case it would end up probably
is the picture beautiful will just end
up being picture picture blank beautiful
or picture beautiful blank I'll have to
think exactly where that thing would end
up so that is fine the tupple
representation would generalize okay and
now the lineman model is also
automatically learned so the model could
learn that the alignment of the word
picture or image or or photo is to the
entire frame and not to some individual
object right so the attention model is
learned it's not something that's hand
coded to say that bike means this object
and girl means this object it's learning
that on its own from training data so if
it has seen enough examples where
someone refers to just the image or just
the photo during training it could learn
in alignment essentially a an attention
map that is very uniform so as it it
decides how much to focus how sharp
their attention map should be based on
the question right so conceptually it
should work out in practice I don't
think we've seen too many examples of
questions like that so chances are if
you won't be able to deal with it very
well but I think the model allows for
that
all right so just to kind of quickly
recap a little bit what I've said so far
so sort of in these abstract scenes the
idea is you're trying to get the machine
to learn as humans are playing around in
different virtual worlds
and what's nice about the set up is one
it gives you a fully annotated visual
data so you can extract whatever
semantic information you want and what's
nice is that it the set up of collecting
data through these interfaces let gives
you full access to sort of gives you
full control over the distribution of
the data that you get right and this is
useful when you're trying to use that as
training data so then you can chew you
can see subtle differences and learn
what the differences mean in terms of
semantics but it's also nice that it
gives you that same controller also for
test data so if I want to be using sort
of visual question answering for example
as a benchmark to evaluate progress on
computer vision tasks I can create a
test set that is as balanced as I wanted
to be so that that measurement is
correlated to progress in computer
vision to the extent that I would like
it to be right you're not the you know
at the mercy of Flickr and Google and
those data distributions and then you
just have to deal with it right here you
have full access to it so I think that's
a nice complementary thing that you get
from this set up to learn from and to
evaluate all right are there any any
questions all right so let me try and
connect this back to the common sense
things that I was saying earlier and
what I'm going to look at our tasks that
are purely text-based so a test time the
input is a piece of text and you need to
make some assessment the Machine needs
to make some assessment that will
require common-sense reasoning right and
so the key idea is going to be that when
you see this text at test time I'm going
to argue that don't that the machine
should not just reason about that text
and make the assessment that it needs to
but it should also imagine the scene
behind the text and use that in making
that assessment right so let me let me
give you an example of this so for
example the tag that purely text-based
tasks could be given at Apple the
machines job is to assess how likely it
is right so let's say on a scale
zero to one how likely is it for a man
to be holding a meal right seems seems
likely enough as opposed to for example
the tree growing in a table right so we
want a machine to realize that this is
more likely than this another example
could be fill in the blank so Mike is
having lunch when he sees a bear and
then what happens right is it a Mike
orders a pizza B Mike hugs the bear see
bears are mammals D might rise too high
right anything most of us would think
that the more likely response is D might
rise too hard right
or this third the last example is a
visual paraphrasing tasks but you're
given two descriptions and the machines
job is to figure out if both of these
descriptions could be describing the
same scenario of the same scene or not
right so Jenni was going to throw hot
pie at Mike Jenni is very angry jenny is
holding a pie right we might go through
reasoning that says when someone is
angry they might throw things at in
order to throw something you have to be
holding in and so these two could be
describing the same scene and so my
argument is that when you're given a
task like this let's say this visual
paraphrasing instead of going through
this explicit reasoning that when you're
angry you throw things and to throw
something you have to hold it and hoping
to learn all of this from text instead
if you just imagine the scene if you
just imagine someone throwing something
you will imagine them holding it right
and so if you imagine the scene be
underlying this text and reason about
similarities in that scene space in
addition to reasoning about similarity
in the tech space you might be able to
better to do better than if you just
written about the text same thing with
this previous example of if you if you
think about what it looks like for a man
to be holding a meal and reason about
how often have I seen this before
instead of just thinking about how often
have I read about men holding meals you
might do better if you reason about that
vision also in addition to the text
right and so that's what we'll go ahead
and do so if your task is this fill in
the blank what we do is we'll plug in
each option into this question so this
gives me a folders full description I've
already told you that we have a way of
generating a scene given an input
description right and so I can go ahead
and loop through all four options plug
them in generate scenes for all four of
these again as a reminder what's
relevant in the scene
is not the RGB values it's not the
pixels right what's relevant are the
semantics right and so we are going to
be imagining these seams in in this
virtual world of the same mic and Jenny
hole that I told you and so we can loop
through that and so for each one of
these descriptions we can generate a
scene that corresponds to it and then
the model that we set up says that the
text with the correct option plugged in
and the corresponding scene all of this
together should score higher then if you
had plugged in the incorrect option and
the image scene that would result from
it right and so we just train a ranked
SVM that extracts features from both the
scene and the text instead of just the
text right and so what we find is this
help so these are accuracies on fill in
the blanks and visual paraphrasing
higher is better this is chance
performance this is what you would do
with text alone so this is sort of our
strong baseline that we are comparing
against this is what you do with vision
alone if you completely ignore the text
and then if you combine the two you see
an improvement in performance more so on
the fill in the blank side this is for
the tupple case where man holds means
versus tree grows and table again higher
is better text alone vision alone and
text plus version right so vision gives
you some improvement over the text one
more thing that we've done sort of to
follow up on this is that do we actually
need to explicitly create the scene -
then reason about it or can the
information of the scene already be part
of the embeddings that are describing
the text right because you're going from
text to images in an automatic fashion
so there shouldn't be anything about
that RGB representation or even the clip
out representation you should be able to
learn that just within the text
embeddings and that's what we've done so
I won't talk about the details of that
what we try to learn embeddings or
representations of text such that
similarity in this new representation
space respect similarity that you would
have had in the generated image space
right and so that that sort of makes our
inference much faster now we don't
actually need to generate these scenes
all right and so one last thing that I
want to talk about and should only take
a couple minutes is pushing this forward
right so with this common sense
reasoning one nice space in which you
can test whether a system has common
sense or not is
with humor and so you wanted to see if
we can get a machine to learn about
visual humor through these abstract
scenes and so the tasks that we might
give a machine or we give the machine a
scene and we ask you to rate on a scale
of 1 through 5 how funny it thinks it is
or we might give it a funny oh yeah I
missed the guy I was like what's funny
about that
well you might still think what's funny
about that but I mean I know what's
supposed to be funny about it so I can
give the Machine a funny scene and ask
you to modify it as little as necessary
so that the scene stops being funny you
might say why would you ever do that so
you can also go the other way that you
start from a boring scene so to speak
and you get the machine to try and make
it more fun alright so these are sort of
the space of tasks that we looked at and
we did what by now you'll probably guess
we would do we asked people to create
just regular scenes we also watch people
to create funny scenes and we can start
and we also gave people then we took one
of those funny scenes went back to other
talkers and asked them to identify what
part of the scene is what's making it
funny and replacing it with something
else so that the scene stops being funny
while still being realistic and
plausible right and then we tried to get
the machine to do the same thing so
here's an example of we give it a funny
scene and the machine is now
automatically identifying which objects
are contributing to humor so the Machine
decided that these three objects are
contributing to humor and then we asked
it to go ahead and replace them with
something that is semantically
meaningful but stops making the scene
funny it chooses to replace a bunch of
things with butterflies because
butterflies can do no harm they're not
funny and you can just kind of place
them so if it's outdoor it matter if
it's outdoor it makes it a butterfly if
it's indoor it makes a reported plant
and then here's one where we are giving
it a boring scene we're asking you to
make it funnier so decides to add these
objects in and we actually test it out
so if we go back to people so this was
the original funny scene and this was
what the machine has now well the
Machine believes it has suppressed the
humour and we ask people which image is
less funny and people do agree that the
suppressed image is less funny so that's
good you can also do like a Turing test
right so this was the original so this
was the not funny scene this is what the
algorithm did to make it funny and this
was the not funny version of this funny
scene that a human had created right so
that entire loop is not important what's
important is this is a not funny scene
this was what a human thought was a
funny version of this this is what a
machine made as a funny version of this
and then we asked people which one is
funnier and humans are still beating us
and so we haven't solved it but 28
percent of the time people think that
the scene that the Machine created was
actually funnier than what a human
created and I thought of that a success
one thing so this is one of the scenes
that our our system thought is the
funniest I think generally when there's
a lot of something the machine tends to
think it's funny
one thing we struggled with was
Mechanical Turk workers would give us
these scenes back and a lot of times it
wasn't like we weren't really laughing
haha out loud at it and so we decided to
ask them why they thought it was funny
like what were you trying to create what
story were you trying to tell and so
this is one example where the worker
explains that this terrified woman's
house is being invaded by mice as the
cat sleeps and that's why it's funny
this one the man is about to trip on his
child's car and spill wine on his wife
which the turgor thought was funny I
don't if I would agree and say yeah so
so just to wrap up I talked a lot about
sort of this visual abstraction space
we've tried to do some fun things with
it things like studying mappings between
vision and language things like zero
short learning where you're learning
what interactions between people look
like without ever - using a real example
just from illustration through this
interactive interface and studying sort
of higher-level concepts like image
memory ability or specificity which I
didn't talk about but something like
visual humor which would be much harder
to get at if you had to rely on
low-level noisy object detector
which are not very accurate right now
and so this is sort of studying high
level image understanding tasks without
having to wait for sort of all the low
level processing to catch up I talked a
little bit about how we can use this to
learn some common sense knowledge and I
think what's exciting about this is
overall that it's a very rich annotation
modality right you can do all sorts of
interactions like I can have a scene and
ask someone to describe it that you can
do with three other images also but now
I can do the flip I can start with the
description and ask people to illustrate
that to me right so whatever it is that
I want to learn if I can convey to a
human they can create a scene that tells
me what that looks like
within the scope of the worship world
that we have I can show you a scene and
I can ask you to modify it in a way that
some property goes up or down for
example humor but it could be other
things and I can put up a scene and ask
you how the meaning changed right so I
think actively exploring this space sort
of really pushing the learning by
playing modality that I was talked about
earlier I think would be very exciting
so this data so it has 50,000 scenes
with captions and questions and answers
and so if anyone's interested you're
welcome to try it out but with that I'll
stop thank you
[Applause]
so so so how exactly were the images
beyond the text so right so I think I
lost or so for each all of the tasks the
approach is slightly different but so if
you're looking at the case where you're
trying to assess how plausible a topple
is what ends up happening is when you
say men or tree grows in table it has
access to a database of these abstract
scenes and it tries to take that
description and see if it can find
support for that description in any of
these images in addition to having a
database of text there are then it has
access to where it also looks for
support right so the baseline approach
just has a database of text and it's
trying to see have I ever read Tree
Grows in table and it you probably won't
find too much support for it but in
addition to that it also looks at a
database of images and sees have I an
reasons about have I ever seen tree
growing in table so if this text
description doesn't match any of the
images that it has seen it will decide
that this probably is not very plausible
and the function that assesses whether a
piece of text matches images or not is
learnt offline through a corpus of
images and associated text right so
offline if you have a database of these
abstract scenes and descriptions you can
learn which text matches which visual
data and that's also what we used for
generating scenes and all of that right
and so through that you can you can read
does that make sense sentence but it's
only when you actually
you will fail to do so right right
one nice example might be that if
someone that it doesn't relate to one of
the specific tasks but just conceptually
if you think about eating versus looking
at in text you wouldn't necessarily
think those are similar so if you look
at like war Toback representations those
are not going to be very close but in
images when someone is about to eat
something they are also looking at it
and so in images you would realize that
actually the process that eating does
imply looking at and so those vectors in
the visuals were to vex space that I was
showing would end up being closer
together and so coming back to that
example of men eating or whether it's
plausible for man to be looking at a
cake maybe people don't talk about that
too much in text maybe people talk about
man eating cake quite a bit but if your
world Toback representation is now
informed by the fact that in order to be
eating something you need to be looking
at it you will now decide that even
though I haven't read men looking at
cake too often I have read man eating
cake too often but the latter will give
me evidence for the former because it's
been informed by the visual world and
not just the text and so there is an
issue of symmetry there that look eating
implies looking at but looking at
doesn't imply eating and yeah we can we
can talk about that more there are ways
of learning embeddings that respect this
order but we haven't done that so far
it's it's not doing very well right at
all like i said that you v the accuracy
that you get by using 50 synthetic
examples it's similar to what you would
have gotten if you had just 3 2 2 3
realistic examples right it's not so
it's it's much better than chance but
it's not a good proxy for real data I
wouldn't say so only if you had concepts
where you really cannot find real like
examples I would suggest that you can
learn it through this this virtual world
but the problem that happens is in order
to ever demonstrate this point we will
need those
examples as test images right so from
just a perspective of running an
experiment and writing a paper and sort
of convincing someone that this makes
sense we can only look at concepts for
which we do actually have real images so
that I can use them as test data yeah so
I guess yeah so I guess so it works much
better than chance but it doesn't work
but yeah the statement is exactly that
the accuracy that you get with 50
examples is what you would get with
three realistic examples anyway so for
that application I would not suggest
that you should use this as a way of
learning if you really cared about an
application of detecting how people
interact I wouldn't suggest that you
should learn it from at least the simple
three-part interface that we have right
for ya for right and then I was trying
to make may be a little too much of a
meta point that the scenarios in which
it would make sense to use this flip-out
interface are scenarios where you really
don't have real examples to learn from
right but then coming back to being able
to conduct an experiment to compute
accuracy of how well you've learnt that
concept you will need test images from
those concepts right you will need real
test images and so you will not be able
yeah maybe we can talk more offline but
as it stands it doesn't work a whole lot
better but I wouldn't suggest replacing
it I think I would keep this last
conversation so we should probably
continue over coffee break Maria
[Applause]